all right this morning I'm going to try as
fast I can't even do a speed install of
icing to my try to get it up in under an
hour is trying hard but if I can get it up
in under an hour an hour and a half I need
to get a test instance of a single up so I
can write some coat against the rest API for
icinga2 and I'm going to jump right into
that and then later on we're going to be
sending a simulated disk disk full messages
from her days to figure out how to speak to
an I sing a system outside of Aries cluster
can't run nice and get into the community as
easily anyway I saw the research I did so
that's what we're going to go do
I said Cisco learning because I've never
done it so if anybody wants to help out let
me know
is it here really anybody to watch right now
first things first
what set out the goals for this little bit
of a learning lab
I come understand
like I single
is an how it came to be
I already know that but I'm going to put
that there
provision avian
refusing to host huizinga
I'm going to need icing and I'll gets
components
Olivia. Sir
I saw that thing in the fantasies like
postgres and everything
a working I single at 2 monitoring system
set up with all its dependencies
on a single server
I see
understand this system
and then it says for an icing installation
I saw that I sing a dependency case install
I Singa
I figure I single to receive alerts
Oakley
we probably do a different lab for icing
yeah we probably do a different one 4
for setting up alerts sending an alarm as it
going to Ronald how's it going expert G
test alert messages
what is a singer that start with the first
thing how we so
is icing a monitoring
and I single stack all right
is coming to an end the latest blog post
monitoring basics back to
here we go and if we terraformed
and yeah I don't have to reform set up
because I don't have a cloud but yeah
that would be something to try for sure
so what is this thing
so just tell me but who knows I want to be
able to set up a monitor and
I need a ride the Monitor and communities so
I'm going to be using mini cube with a VM
driver in order to feel the disc without
blowing them at my work station away if that
which is what would happen if I use a darker
as a driver I'm going to use Uber as a
driver which I got working last night and
I'm going to write the monitor for the full
disco in PVC and I want to have it be able
to send a message to I single which is going
to be running on another vml play on the
same network and I'll probably have to
bridge the networks are to make it happen so
I need to set up a single to do that so I
need a machine on Mean Machine on Mean
Machine For That
cell
how to get started getting shower this
weekend so I think it is that monitoring
solution and it was born from nagios it's
been off for a while and caters to
Enterprise but it's in a slack integration
it's how many companies send slack
notifications rather than writing their own
Bots it already has all of that and Elsa has
a dashboard and its own pseudo language
it was your first full stack Monterey
Enterprise solution insulation course for a
Stressless start with the singer your online
name of the first impression we sing at
we're going to go ahead and follow the docks
as best we can all the courts of February on
supposed to monitoring system at the end
you'll be able to monitor your servers and
works in applications I don't have a long
time for this so I'm going to try to finish
this and then an hour an hour and a half to
Aditi I don't think it is it is closer to
Nadia's
do you want to relearn about Madhuri bases
get from are the senators in general and you
icing a way of monitoring I can just tell
you I think I may have modules that you can
put on systems and you can have a model for
anything and then that model just sends up
you know some of the mothership that's all
it really is
every easy way to start working at least two
gigs Ram two or more cores I sent you was
for the operating system and Apache web
server wow that's that's a lot of
information that's exactly what I needed to
do so let me go ahead and use maygrant to to
provision this since we got bigger it to
work yesterday finally I need to find you a
bunch of image
I'm going to get ahead of myself though are
you mean
are you started working at least 200 GB of
RAM trim or cars or since I stopped
Bernice's to Apache web server and might as
well as any of us so those are all things
that have to be
things that have to be installed yeah but
still
and gangly out for y'all but I'll get it
yeah I know this is the one we have to use
alright so let's get it sent his box set up
I'm going to step two understand sister
Penzeys original version machine someone
else at 3 already
I need to set up a vagrant job 2
pull down at Evian freysinger
so I'm going to try this I haven't going to
snow while
regrets
I got to make sure it gets to the doctor.
The doctor image the diagram which is the
only thing you want to use I did a whole
video on that last night if you want to go
watch a bigger and we finally got it to work
is it dead in the water I don't think it
said we use it at work everyday all the time
so I don't think it's dead
what were you what were you sitting what
would you think would be a new thing
what is a more modern alternative to icing
go I think about Prometheus and that kind of
stuff
as if working. Guess is Backward Compatible
well not always but yeah in this case it's a
I taking you your browser I'm also trying to
read here cuz I'm watching other stuff at
work
I had to complete a captcha I don't want to
complete a captcha piece of shit Cloud Fair
I hate fucking hate Carver
when I gave him a general the way depending
datadog free this was her phone again yeah
those are things that we do have those in
the Enterprise but we still have a single
left around
that's why I don't want to spend a lot of
time on it dog years is the older version
is Narnia still supported imagine it is
I thought I didn't like nobody else is
probably I got a lot more usage out there
leftover
spiceworks have never heard of datadog I
know it's been off forever I just paid them
they've been a mess out here that one he's.
That's that's no
am I checking on RT Pandora observium none
of these or any good
I think I think Nadia's going to be the most
popular it's also the oldest
zabbix I haven't heard of though
I understand electricity support as much as
usual as I get notified about coronavirus
isolation without delay
I don't have for me feel so sit here at all
is Prison Break is it just a coronavirus
check
I mean I could have that wrong with
Prometheus elasticsearch that,
prices of star systems monitoring and a
learning tool kit to do my SoundCloud is
this after 2012 many countries in
organizations without the Prometheus and
retracted lots of times I don't understand
why
we might we might have to do it for me if
you sing to
I I personally don't necessarily want to
useall the time I just have to support it so
never heard of Jack Diamond there's a tons
of stuff
so Francis has is the first alternate that
comes to my mind open source has learning
tool kit
the price is very active in the community
this is true is now stand alone open source
project which is apparently in the company
Timber sizes and your car for the price of
governance practices join call native
after communities place in stores in
Massachusetts and Sarah's data right or
you're free this is like an alternate being
Flex I think it's got more stuff to it
I mean teachers most Edition model promise
you all kind of hate it from Carol I'm
serious data or the metrics
Pine Bush is exporters race is written in go
this is the one I want to get into
Resorts World of a of the America Center is
data machine says you're muttering as well
it's kind of like collecting logs
nice is not about logging it's about
monitoring the messages so I don't know
I don't know if your major thing I don't get
well enough of that
I'm going to put something like this
I put a warning
and this is my situation I have to have the
support this I don't I don't think it's dead
though
I mean certainly. Dead in our company
you're not on this particular point I don't
think that they're like you know the most
advanced thing and has all
I just busy running basics
singers will send you the one with the
ecosystem. That's old when was this song
written 2021
I think it's relatively new to this is
interesting
I find this fascinating
my guess and I singer
this is 121 I don't have a lot of time to
the time I need to set up no matter what but
I do want to understand it better so I can
make sure condition I think it was the New
World Systems Monterey even though it has
been around for over 10 years a great
features and it's a standalone solution for
systems and every Monday August is a
well-established product an enormous
community supports increase for add-ons for
this product pricing as soon as I was that
is free and open source software own
audience isn't I guess which means it can be
fairly disturbing with the source code and
customers we can meet me at my place only
place that products like I seen you can
start to cost you money is in the support of
development categories like it has a price
tag of 2000 when did they start charge as
they always charge your phone I guess I've
never paid for novios
but that price includes some support if you
need it
this makes sense a larger part of vitamins
that so you can decorate the technologies
that only customer software which is
possible and I'll guess I'll take a closer
look if you're looking for a rear bumper for
liability and argues
11 is just a solution free where you looking
it has both monitoring and system alert now
get us off his analytical insights
add your devicedevice coronavirus Brazos in
Cornelius Naga City tomorrow afternoon
services at Wes's
Nargis features I sing I sing it was
initially arrested May 28th 2009 that's why
I never heard of it and undergone many
updates and upgrades at most functional
missile over the years Bowser's projects
gain massive fan base in Montgomery Fanatics
and it is functionally that you would expect
to find only in an expensive Enterprise
solution I think he uses a similar series of
plugins and add-ons and I guess that's what
I was talking about and that is because I
think it began Life as a broken record for
Nadia's although some would argue that this
thing has become a mature and stable enough
to be on his own a single operates through
several different modules namely a
single-core any I singer
I need to go on stage I forgot I need to go
on stage with Discord just give me a second
okay so I think operates three different
modules name in a single-core on the icing
user interface
user interface is available as a visual
interface and as a command interface
I think I managed to retain compatibility
with then I guess in some ways it can even
use the cnrp remote plug an Executor ass and
remote systems Winery tool on all my single
offers all the essential functionality that
moment expecting a scalable feature-rich
monitoring solution and the community offers
a lot of support material information help
you get started for him or any support you
can request a quote for here
zabbix vs. nagato is obvious according to
Alternatives that I owe was was Isaiah was
higher in popularity than obvious as the top
alternative to I think a so I'm just trying
to get a lay of the land here what are the
main differences even have to open this when
are graphene is a table
before you go God
do I get her ego Nadia's versus cacti
comparison somebody in this chat and mention
cacti
so much time spent in there yeah most of us
have right I feel like more of you
okay so stop Express is not guess what are
the main differences
and I guess and I seem to have all of the
same things
icmp SNMP deviously Modern Hardware
monitoring Webster laundry actor-director
alerts reporting Graff small are smart
device to the game
everything about these solutions that there
is definitely room for customization
Treasure Trove of plugins
pill for small-scale businesses companies
have save money
having a free monitoring tools such as I
think is a good way of your small business
now I guess it was support as part of the
package
this makes sense if your services pay for
product can give you the support when you
need it can be a valuable so you can't pay
for an enticing I guess actually no download
its wavefunction version August run for 60
days and this is I did not know nobody else
is proprietary I don't know where I miss
that both of these projects give you vision
and today's stuff you need I will come down
and went to which of these two pieces of her
fits your better if you had to pick one and
probably nagas 11 just for the fact that is
such a reputation in this tree I've heard so
many great features of the boss connection
support when is proprietary that there is a
lot of looks like about both these products
not going to offer support and maintenance
plan to meet your budget August Licensing
Spokane to be here and I'll fuck that I
thought was pretty good right up so
see what else how do you say sing it to
monitor your services Services entering a
single till that next ocean Bay. Anytime you
find any blogs on digitalocean make sure to
read them because digitalocean pays their
bloggers for their contributions and they
get really Kick-Ass great stuff I cannot
tell you I have been so impressed how to use
a singer to monitor you have a pay
independent blockers for high quality
content
they tend to be better than everything else
your servers
and services yeah I'm not interested
yeah it'll be dealt and that's never going
to be in the colonel it'll be you know that
right
they openly stated emphatically rust will
never be in the colonel it will maybe be
supported for drivers
so stop saying it's going to be in the
colonel to lie that's in Spring Boot and
Alternatives not working on that right now
Kevin Love workout informations area liver
yesterday
terraform we we decided you can't have
terraformed without a cloud and so I got
bigger into work instead
Easy Lover and that's why we drink today is
because that's what it's designed to do
drivers are not carnal code
yeah they're not in their mind probe into
the colonel that that's not Colonel Cody
sorry no but you can't convince me otherwise
you can try drivers do not count let most of
the stuff is is that we use everyday is a
driver I get it it's pretty damn close to
the colonel I definitely calls into the
colonel directly but it is not strictly
speaking it is not Colonel code
a very specific targets protocol find to
change the graphics inside the map to make
the right icons bigger so I had to download
the source and take a seat file
did you ever doubt how did you do that when
I get there I think they have a f support
right so I think that was what was going on
all right so it's been and would you like to
share the snow
how do you say sing the money or services
are in Oracle 14 and a bun 24 can put on
that's pretty oldest 2014
is it 2014 I guess that's kind of cool. Just
me just been around for awhile
I mean I don't know if it's the wrong it's
about all the other all right back to what I
was doing I don't want to get too distracted
we need to get a ride so we need to go get a
vagrant soon system up and running
we need install I'm going to South Central
us on a VM using vagrant
with the other support
and see if any permits you
yeah that's another it's another terraform
issues like the one that we had before
LaVergne telephone provider oh nice thank
you
yeah Mission denied
Isis count diminished default
Ice Princess and miss you
yeah isn't issue is part of the liver
configurations yet
does not mean you're an eraser this is that
comment is really stupid
I don't want to get sucked into this right
now
I just want to say thank you for posting to
suffer
and it came is fine generated
I guess somebody wants to see it I'm just
reading this little bit learning
documentation
I started to see Lenox
Air France is a homeowner upset that this is
exactly what it is actually not terraform
doing this live bird doing that
and they were fix us known issue that
farmers Hanley volumes from look for
Mexican singer of Liberty ISO doesn't change
permissions it's a liver problem
I fix this problem with this
okay play mind if I work around is security
driver none we did this
a system restart we did that very thing
double check that driver doesn't run I tried
that and it didn't fix it unfortunately
delivered
I think we need to actually change the
security driver equals then let me go check
this another project but
when is it Lambert's
Kimu
week we had to change the the owners of the
group ownership
the extra driver's license able as a result
of a screwdriver exactly none is a special
buy screwdriver can be set to that value in
isolation but it cannot appear in a list of
drivers
I mean I don't have a problem with it
that that I thought we did that one but just
not at tour list of fixes
starts convert G
others have reported that
disabling the security was it
there's like a plethora of fixes for this
plethora would you say you have a plethora
when you say you have a plethora
I think this is an SE Lennox problem just
might actually pop up now that we're using
Cent OS for hosting because it has selinux
on by default I've heard I have not use it
ever so we're going to go get at
thank you for sending that suffer I'll go
have a look at that
appreciate that I do want to get that
dashing Ben is there a liver Dash bin I
didn't know there was a liver Dish been
I doubt there is none of the liver d think
I'm
it is a part of a generation oh
I want disable default policy to create
what the hell it is very long
I don't know systemctl logging I got to go
look it up
I checked the log it would have been a rose
status is there an option to check full
system D service on file with you let's go
journalctl is something I have never use
it's it's relatively new to the admin tires
just go to Vlog with
external seat l s u and I know I got really
old semi skills really dated
Journal ctls you Len Birds d
a hostname to make a screwdriver
why isn't that one why is it rapping I don't
understand
it should not be rapping and shouldn't
bubble bubble bubble
nice
how far is it to the policy to create
confined guests
hope policy create can find guess and
support a configuration security driver at
model is not available
who's trying to do that I make sure I didn't
kill my virt-manager
the vagrant default
Zoe got running
nothing like it weren't raining yesterday
socially actually now it's use it later to
Metairie
yeah we got we got a lot of stuff from
yesterday that's nice right out the back
that out but I don't see you now
I got to learn journalctl I have to do for
that damn it
I guess I just do it's like a mandatory
thing I know it is and I just again it's one
of the many things that have to catch up on
which you know kind of came about because
if add to my list of notes
I think of what we're doing we're installing
CV to get back I'll recommend resources for
installing am I single so I can do my
testing for work today
so yeah let's go back
where to go to
trying to decide whether we need to make a
beacon fire or not for this probably do
listen to it I think a bigger and file and
then call down to
so just do that I don't remember a bigger I
think it's bigger than it
now that's using its getting its give me
this stuff right here because it's running
as a Docker container which is the only way
we can get it to work it's actually pretty
fast to get it work that way and it includes
delivered so far by the fault so I strongly
recommend doing that
figuring files is a big ass any of this
stuff we're going to do
I'm going to go here how can link and go
look at my lips
I think I think it's generic sent to us but
I don't know
Cento S7 what's the most recent version of
sent to us
that was over a year ago
what's up in the sky actually Cent OS
generic centos7 yet let me see 18 days ago
all right we got it
all right secrets
Cento S7 I think we need the rest of this
we need to vm's which I think we get by
default
vagrants to CPU
I don't know how to do this stuff somewhere
look it up real quick
customize 2
if I let me go
and provided does it have to be by the for
the if you're running liver provider YouTube
to the lines like this
as soon as I can. I have to find you have a
lot to receive your new favorite machine
editor file
I'm thinking about like this
is there is if you when you're slicing a
banger by McPherson file for making a scrape
on his details actual purpose of your family
as described here
immigrants remarks
so you do have to do it
yeah you have to do it by by thing
liver fry can make me a provider memories of
used to
what were the constraints kicking around two
more cars
ticking around two more cars so that should
work
ruby yeah I know I do like really I wish
wish we could use it more but I don't
remember it I don't I do not remember it
so let's do that let's do vagrant
up and that should actually pull the boxes
well
yay it's working
the too early for this probably
they just wake everybody up with your whole
family up
I only killed my machine trying to run a
video and a VM at the same time
play some I didn't crash
it's definitely hung that is weird Repose
gray and yes please
that is so weird
I computer is not have a look at pump
Alyssa's shit voice is really shit lately I
am just going to say it like this it doesn't
draw anything this is happened to just like
every probably every 3 days has happened to
me
and I beat my my workstation to death no
doubt but still
I can't say that we have to reboot machine
is ready
vagrants is ready I just can't see anything
Define I am going to pick you up from
another terminal
I can't even add a new turn on cuz I can't
fucking see anything
that's okay she'll right there and then we
go to terminal fuck
pastry dough a new window new new window
this is
and look it works then what's your full
screen this guy
hey I got it back yay God dammit still a
fucked up.
Do we know when the salmon don't lie is it
I don't know I have been using it look it's
crashed on me at least four times as you
steam
is he doesn't even approve thing
hey by the way sister is it might be I'm
running out I mean there's a bunch of
distros are the standard workstation for
gaming and everything like that so
I'm seriously thinking about going back to
Linux Mint though
Vince I don't know why I don't want to lose
all my gaming everything too so I promise
I'm not going to do anything to the truth
cuz I want to store my games and stuff but
I'll just complain forever right we have our
machine up now so
researches going to show us our machine
that was status what does it list and every
go so we have a lot of things that we have
allowed vagrant to fault
remember Phil are probably take down for cuz
these things are heavy
let's do that vagrants I want to see verse
Holts hello what is it
I don't know her ass for real I got to learn
it it halter stop or something
I meant all the things ever gave me
I know my jarosz shit I will never use it
it's the only distro that's bricked my
entire fucking lab I felt ever ever use it
not to mention their commute the people that
run in absolute Crooks
corporate perks of the worst kind yeah I
will never touch my girl
hey I love you please my job but it's too
bad she bad I feel sorry for you
like people getting caught in using my
drawers are first thing because I'm told you
it's run by corporate Crooks who got a full
marketing system going on
is that why your Papa's going to Papa's to
get somebody suggested last year 2 years ago
and it just worked and it got rid of all the
you if I issue the beginners were having and
that means did not do well and because they
did some cool stuff at the low-level and now
they're just doing too much cool stuff
I don't want to like electrical stuff
they're doing like trying to read right
though fucking desktop and rust how fucking
stupid do you have to be to rewrite
something that already works at supported by
an entire Community for more than a decade
just cuz you want to rewrite it and rust
good luck with that spend all of your
all of your money on that what a great
decisions system76 goodbye
yeah it's like it sounds like a fun project
just not necessary
whoever is whoever is running the technology
over there doesn't have a fucking clue
forget my system 76 bunch of shit if I just
blew it they don't whoever's going to spend
all the HR money because people are the most
expensive thing on rewriting an entire
fucking desktop that already just works you
only got three or four options out there why
not get behind one of those instead of
rewriting the whole fucking think the
problem with system76 is there starting to
get successful and so they're starting to
not give a shit about their users or they
could do instead keep this from happening
but they fix their fucking another going to
show this is the reason we need to rewrite
it because this is no problem and I can't
read anything at all the menus or fucked up
and blah blah blah blah blah blah blah they
could have contributed to fix this issue but
instead they won't they could have not
gotten rid of my search ability from from
here
without having to click on applications and
had to just work they cannot just stop
fucking around the desktop and listen to the
user that they don't want him anymore
because he's getting big system 76 getting a
big head and they're starting to make a
bunch of stupid ass decisions you don't
believe me ask Line-X does Linus Tech tips
oh that would never happen in Rust yeah
built-in protection
okay it's never a good idea to rewrite an
entire thing just because it has a couple
bucks
I do it all the time it's still not a good
idea good for me the X-Men I will never
change you to act like
all right so back to something useful
unable to watch The Watcher plasma screen TV
Guide
keep my screen key doesn't work now are
there we go again
it's let's go alright so we did it ya a team
I wasn't too fast too long much time you got
everything going
pina colada
all right so it's all right to course around
we just did and we we we provisioned with a
couple lines of vagrants so I'm happy
okay we need to have from his second Apache
web server am I supposed to be a base so
what I want to know is if they want the
Apache web server to be on its own system
I feel like the answer to that is yes
I kind of want to make a an ansible roll it
brings up the patchy why do you have to have
a patchy can't we use nginx
as his representative patch I'm serving my
schedule a fucking hate my Askew all we need
is postgres and nginx
I mean if it can't run on the same system
can I want to do this with the with ansible
I know there's an ansible rule for putting
nginx on there
yeah
read that either way I said it came in a
razor yeah I think it means a get the
machine running and then put these things on
the machine I think that's what it means or
not Apache is the will gobble up all tickets
around like immediately it's fucking memory
hogeye Minister that for years
I'm I'm I don't know if we're going to
figure this out
this is really a good opportunity for me to
learn how to use it ansible and like do the
do the provisioning yeah
you probably need to include a single.
Confident that you know, yeah I don't know
what's going on and see
Mexican sauce thing that used to sing about
just play it again I single
is it there is there an as well provider for
Apache web server I bet there is
are using a single 0 10 x but it's a good
too
I got using a single though so it's what I
want to make sure we have any dependencies
here
yeah I did I read I brought my stress and a
singer in the sunplate I mean and nginx in
someplace else I just don't think it's in
this particular tutorial
yeah the comedian thank you for that convey
recommendations Sentosa patchy watch over my
child there to give his recommendations
I saw a single web so I think that's it I
saw a single Heaven instead of saying it to
I send it to get the director game hey hi
so let's go get is there an ansible role to
install
I know I'm I've never done it so don't laugh
ansible
install engine it's got to be and an x on
with vagrants
there's a Playbook this place is everything
as well
animal playground Andrea shoes ansible
and the reason as well so I just spoke to
her Ash Wednesday services
video streaming down with vagrants managex
as long as you so I can figure
out of commission is extra figurines
I mean let's go read it
Hey look it's not even doing my terminal
properly now
hopeless I'm telling you dude pop OS has
gone to shit
a razored edge X let's go to little bit
further
30 Vigor environment did it bigger than its
nipple
as you can see in the trees haven't even
make you some blah Lenox of course yes
welcome and have a vagrant system
highlighting the vagrants if I was writing
Ruby
a material theme why
oh my God. Jesus yell provisioner
to have the test, so I can take something
for something for us
when you find a message this one I'll just
make it to the shell script
he's a shell provisioner that seems like
cheating
I'm selling it and since I think I'm talking
to it over rest
a divorce in a single yes please that might
be the one
how to Shell how to shell script install an
STI Singa
we just had your apps install
they gave us of our finding work yes
an original Up is on this telecast including
all the warnings and chunky chunky Chompie's
in one who got it to work because he had had
the same problem before are they I don't
know what they are they and got it to work
before confirm the file is correct bigger
notes
so this actually is just a song nginx like
from the command line using the Shell
provisioner which I did not know you could
do Indigent I mean it's cheap and dirty way
to do it when
the way to do it when you don't want to fuck
around with
you know I mean that's just like a cheap and
dirty way to do it without without fucking
raw with ansible
well I mean it's why he's bigger I have it I
get to sense there's a lot of overlap
between Vega and Turner forum and its
ability to make it install and do shit
that's not designed to do that was one
example
set up for forwarding configure Network
440-8280
it means that we can browse to on your way
soon as your server you never forwarded
Portage s a t o c a t a t i n g Nikes with
this change we should be able to launch a
browser and see the engine x with a right
away
Jay Anthony time you change a bigger file
and the first machine is already running
you'll need to run a vagrant reload
as a thing bigger reloaded the thing I did
not know this
yep vagrants I know I went from being a
hater on it to loving it
configure game. For minor shell
I'm going to have to do an apt update I
would think
I don't think
yep that way that way that's a config
vagrant config 2
do is fig. VM
provision Shall Pass provision. Sh
Crystal scripture telling me it's that easy
it's like a Docker file
I think I can actually just run it I can
take that damn provision she'll path
is really it holy cow a super cool
pig perfume for vision
shell pass
vision it seems like cheating
I mean
provision Ash on
I can't touch my update I feel like I'm
running a Docker file for God sake
Afghan that's why it stall
nginx and wanted posters on there
service engine start no
no it's just a c c l
i don't know actually you know the stew
let's see if we can get this work
this time actually it's going to start
automatically Anixter Saint Michael
how do you say what is a plus for us install
I think it's
I think it's I want to say
happy tea
Sommer Ray oh God went the other day be in
pages
yep it's very that postgresql well let's try
it
vagrant what did I say I think it's a Reload
at the bottom here vagrants
reload
I don't know what's going to do or is he
still shut down at the end God damn this is
cool
is it really fucking cool hey how are you
wow Let's go over here
my route status
nginx that doesn't make me happy
God damn it I just don't think it ran it
by the way my weight machine already
provision run vagrant provision to use the
provision
prisoners March run always will still run I
think I missed something here
or make or a Jackson make the changes to
take it back to a ha
fragrance risen shit
we talking about oh it's red at it's red hat
I feel really stupid in a long time I
provision redhead server
since I worked at I am I'm not even kidding
this is the first time I've ever seen a
redhead server in since 2012
it has been 10 years since I've been there I
don't even know you at all
no is a million things wrong here
so let's let's see if I can actually do it
for the command line this is probably the
bad day to choose to do this with redhead
but whatever
I need to get my red hat skills back up
I do I am I am not my redhead is not any
good
but young shit I haven't done it young man I
haven't had in 20 years
yeah I know usually but not always update
sudo yum
all I seem to be working
all right
is this okay do you think that's okay no
I want to try I try my provisioning again
vagrant
start a Skype vagrant provision
oh hey look at looks happy Alex happy
it's green that's good right well football
scouts a first person or two
all right that was some serious happiness
if he wants to know where the questions
needed what's needed
and that's why oh yeah that's why I've
always needed I'm pretty sure it's the only
needed do I need an apt
and if it's needed for r.e.m.
so that would be a difference between the
two definitely if that's true I feel good I
feel like I feel kind of proud
how safe will to do that in one command I
mean come on this is why I spent three days
busting my head on ki-moon KVM vagrant
terraform ansible and all this shit because
even if your community's person you still
need to bring shit up fast to do testing and
to do things so you still need to be an
infrastructure engineer the reason my job
description says we don't just want devops
Engineers is because they need people that
know how to do this other stuff and it's
been a while since I've done that so I'm
it's good that I'm updating speaking of work
I'm reading our stand-ups which is over
nothing in the stand up
if it's deaf people advised up on time all
working hard I am going to try my hardest to
work a regular nine-to-five
session
so because I just feel like it's a better
thing to do with my work environment because
they work 9 to 5 or 4 or so so I'm actually
going to try really hard to maintain a
traditional work schedule I'm going to try
to drop my bimodal sleep schedule
because it's more important that I'm
available for work that it is that my sleep
work better I could probably still do
bimodal it just means I'll have to go to bed
as soon as I get out of work
so I don't know if you got up you don't know
what I'm talking about and go back and read
my by modal sleep.
All right so so so so so so so so I have a
provision thing I'm going to set up walk
around and get a little bit more decaf
coffee and I think I lost another job as
soon as I already so yeah for sure no do a
pincher yeah well
so so yeah
there's one thing that stopped me sleep
exactly one point where the problem with
sleep for me is is having to be at a
consistent time frame schedule that is super
hard for me I don't operate that way and
I've I've I've I've pulled back on the
alcohol alcohol and caffeine or the things
that will fuck your sleep up there more than
anything else that those two things actually
really disrupt your sleep so I was doing
both so I pulled back on the caffeine today.
Must not have went to bed early instead of
playing with her and tell God awful early
hours in the morning
but I know we're going to we're going to
find out no promises no promises but you can
let my body do its thing I'll see when I get
back to doing yoga in the morning and that I
miss it a lot actually
while there's a big old thread going on
about replacing go that's cool so
I mean I'm surprised at how fast it was it
when we definitely got it up we got we got
it we got the new provision do we got to
here
we got to hear
in an hour so that's really great that took
us about an hour to do all that so that was
you cuz of vagrant
install a single configure I seen her she
looks okay I'm going to set up make some
coffee come back and we're all ready to go
we're going to do the eye thing is so now if
everything goes well I'll have it done by by
noon I'll have I seen a completely installed
by newest are playing with it for this
afternoon and I need to write a rest API
query to talk to it and I need to figure out
what I want to do that with curl or because
I need to report I may be something in my
running go on and we'll see
nothing for the afternoon so the afternoon
if you want to see me codeine alerts that
are going to send off a single messages
that's going to be this afternoon I need to
I need to get Cooper days to go fishing if
we don't have that many Cube nevermind I
forgot
I'm going to take a break
that way when you eat your head gets cold
Amazon
blood leaves your body I guess go to your
stomach
DeKalb most anybody worry
all right my God is so good
so good coffee is good when it's asleep
snowing outside
I feel good but not just coffee cuz decal
let's do this
how's it going at show welcome
so what's up you're too young to remember
that
Allah
I definitely mean
my head is cold Brioni
Biryani I keep saying Brioni cuz I'm
dyslexic
cornholio
I know this is not a fashion statement it's
just cuz my fucking head is freezing
listen to the fashion statements about
against his butt or into comfortable head
oh God we got we got like 45 in like 2 days
ago it's almost all melted though cuz it's
North Carolina
so far so good stop for Santa
Electronics Arduinoyou know what oh my God I
want that
I want that
I wasn't doing what was we doing what was we
doing for the english-speakers out there
that is not English when I just said
I've shipped my teeth and Fall Guys
I used to care about how I look Downstream
now it's like fuk I don't care I said I
still like watching a I was considering day
I like watching a you like really didn't
give a shit in like
and I was like wearing a cop going to give
it and now it's like I don't give a shit I
just put Matthew
I don't care I don't care it's probably
normal anyway
we have a system that is up and running
ready to take izinga and
was I single as we said I think that is a
monitoring system comprable to nagios came
from. I guess
and that is all X Elizabeth this line of
reconfigure your network in here shall we
it's certainly not going to hurt hey
hamdog oh God
when is your name scumdog Rascal what a name
what a name that is
what I should say I should yell at because
it's capitalized
what does
a Russian one.
Host 8080 ID nginx
on investing work should we try it
somebody's using the bathroom you can hear
from here they couldn't provision
0111 is unhappy
I wish because if it was weird ass quotes in
there that was weird
all right
Vigor from the docker file might be a little
slower on Startup but it is so much more
reliable
this is you don't run it all the time I mean
like you know performacide nothing to do it
says
Evelyn's place that's why I like speeds
vagrant reload mr. robot robot OST
Kelly Provost Mister roast
please mr. Candyman horsefly for
provisioning
anyway I want to go to this that's what I
should be doing right
hated it
there is 8280
wow I love egg right now I was so mad at it
before now I love it
what else is new
enough of this page don't need anymore
definitely my thing my notes that's in my
notes
you guys did Frank you approve I know you're
Mister low-level device guy to prove that
call Wright cell
we have a current here ready to do anything
oh yeah
if you think it's worth getting I might go
buy it anyway I mean
who is Scott circus of shit in there
did you hear humblebums going away I heard
somebody said that
do you like Alexa's or processing
offer ends in 20 days
I don't want that free email
create an account nope PayPal
I skis and buy another one more thing since
Frank says is good
I bought a lot of books to read I'm going to
be I don't know if I'm going to renew online
or not
where you guys think it's kind of like a
gray area copyright wise but I think it
would be kind of fun to read through some of
these books online together
would it be more valuable
I think we'll be fine as long as I told
everybody else is a hey we're going to be in
this book and go by after the burial
what's the country to see stuff on Saturday
but like in my own time I got me to be
reading it I bought all those ansible books
that had 10 is suggested and I want to go
read those
and so there is some that's why. He's the
guy that guy wrote acordes book I don't know
how good it looks going to be bumps going to
be an excellent way to write my own of
course
well that was easy
please try again soon
PayPal prefer balance wait
your payment is pending
looks like it's fine again
very eclipse or pants more closely hell
right
God gave me you should about that one
because it was like you might be getting
owned
if I can be available on Linux that's what I
heard that's what I read yeah
they deliberately sent out Noah next why the
fuck would they do that
stupid that's why they think this could be
safer on Mac and windows not it's not it's
not going to be safer
dim
hurry back to what we're doing what what are
we doing we were trying to
what what I want to hate if I buy The Humble
stuff in and thenThe Humble stuff in and
then all the sudden doesn't run on Linux a
minute I got to be stuck
but I can barely even read it because I'm
using Linux I'm going to pull my back out
I can do that I guess I have to do that now
so that worried about it
I need to know that because if that's true
I'm going to be like not buying stuff on
humble anymore
ever so
like almost as a matter of principle don't
want to spend a single dime over there
anymore
because of that at such a dumbass decision
maybe because I don't understand it
I wasn't I don't I've never bought anything
from her but I don't know how they deliver
the stuff to you the statement that they're
going to make their own launcher makes me
think that they're going to hide their stuff
behind like a Kindle kind of situation
that PDF again then a fine
ultimately that's what I want to do I just
want to add into my big PDFs collection and
just call it a day and I want to fuck it up
then yeah I got a USB with PDFs
I said is he library then probably I don't
even know what that is
back to the task at hand we need to install
Tysinger I'm going to follow the directions
what is this I just had to install stuff
postgres what you don't need anymore
I saw a single web I need to install game
guess I was a single download installation
course
well that's what I'm reading I'm reading I
sing as anybody else but then other people
say it's it's not being used that much and
I'm like
I don't know I use it at work that's why I'm
in footing on I would be inclined to use for
me if he has instead but I'm not completely
sure for me this isn't only an caretti SEC
because I haven't I haven't look deeply
enough does anybody know
Prometheus is Prometheus and grafana are
kind of like the modern thing
they still think he's well how's the car
keys for you in a game nice
well
give me the full second reprise water
solution for the installation course for a
stressful start with a single visiting
online demo
for first impression of you sing a s I like
to try the demo
all the insulation course below
I can post a thing I thought about that but
I don't know
I look like I'm going to do a VM I'm doing
any VM I'm going to start using ATMs in
general over darker because it's more real
and I've already hit one situation where I
need an actual device I can fill up the snow
disc and and doctor would not have covered
it
so I'm I it's funny because I know the
beginning of the year people are saying why
are you doing all of that in a container you
can eventually needed device then they were
right so
Mercedes New Relic now
follow this course to set my very own
supposed to marry system from the any
reminders or new tomorrow and learn about
Monarch basics in
no I didn't say via VIA more Docker I used
to set up I just I have a question,
workspace container which I use a darker
which I still do for Education stuff which
is essentially you know everything you would
know from the command line but it's not but
you need to become a technician operations
person you usually need to be up because
you're you're trying to test the limits of
systems and you're trying to break shit and
you cannot break shit with darker bottom
line I need to write that down and said
create
you cannot
break shit with doctor I have come to the
reality
that most of the development and operations
testing requires me to stress systems to
their
two again
better performance and monitor for
capacity situations well
most devil work yeah
well such things are simply unsafe to do
with an emulated Linux system running within
a Docker container
this includes development I have four things
that
involve systems
at a lower level in the Enterprise
architecture
filling a PVC storage class for example
even though containers are fine for most
other
Cloud native applications development ants
hence kind
this means that I have been using minikube
with
the live Birds
a driver and vagrants a lot more lately
as an infrastructure engineer
structure h e r n s r e type person
I like writing code
that either blows shit up or prevents it
from being blown up
vm's are the only safe playground
for that kind of development
shit Domino's down again I got to go check
this
Liam Smith
what's the difference between a cloud
instances of Ian or are they wire are they
Barbara Ferrer
Mel let me start that work for Content
working a container for most of
dumb after I have to go look at this
it would be an environmental in the cloud
I'm going to say all right I have to read
this this afternoon I have to read this
stuff from work I might be off the screen
for a bit
and some Freedom 87 Mower and dominoes down
all right
yeah B Honeywell
learn Basics recommended resources we did
that already
what is this download thing about just
started download what is that about
download icing gun I highly recommend to use
artificial ice packs to install a singer
official single repository provide the most
recent packages for leading operating
systems from a sign of the coming above the
law
sent to us well
package Repository
Center West 7 right
I got to stay for vpl right by so make sure
you're still a pill release look at that
I said it was 7 a single with two will also
require PHP via the scl depository system
hey we can have the star vagrant
we need to start earlier and file provision
and sent his release as CL
okay redhat incompatible
dnf install unless anti-nausea
I guess your manager
install is this it
RPM import I sing a keys
do you know f install
cuz brings back memories as of right eye
pain or being packages
and then you install as a point of their apt
thing alright I'm going to try to
alright I'm going to try to reposition to
see it expert G
her name is a these bills with your not
recommended for Russian use please use the
release packages instead
I did apps that Bill's not interested
I just try to reload
when did the hard way reload provisioned so
redo are provisioning god dammit School
waiting for the machine to boot
uh oh is there a Justice how do we have for
stats in
Emily destruction saved as in light reaction
what did I forget to put in at Hawaii on dnf
command not found
what is dnf
I don't know I haven't used our favor
forever
do you know stands for dandified yum
it sits out for a package manager for a
previous relationship is it still updating
remove package in the central us operating
system is a default package manager for 8
the next-generation version of yum and
intend to be replaced with volume and RPMs
systems did not know this
set create Dandy fide
young is new yum
I didn't go I don't have any good
recommendations for go unfortunately no is
my best
I guess recommendations right now or just
through the docks
and just Coral definitely needs his manager
what is makes me wonder if
if this is like an option is like either
this oh wait that's if you're on this is up
here on 8th
and not seven so the Danny fight thing is
only 48
holy shit okay oh now I know now I know and
I can fix it
vagrant definition don't need that
get ready for a lot of documentation
to be wrong
the dnf command
is the standard as of Cent OS 8
before that everything is yum
all right
see if we can reprovision
we actually have to get all this installed
or just run from a script wouldn't that be
glorious
follow the course doesn't seem like there's
a course
I get my p.m. p.m. Rocio, I knowI know
no this is his command it's a rerun it with
whatever
is this okay laughing
why
I take back everything that is said about my
rent
yay hey look I think it is now installed
officially holy shit that was easy
now you need to install a sink at 2
you need to see me at 2 to collect the data
in your monitor and say cancellations
fractions we just did it
and learn how to run and connect it to your
database that's going to do that
this is where the seven step instruction is
selling a single too and is he going to as
soon as I hear from their the operating
system
I'm not but okay
all right we're very close to the answer may
be done before noon though probably
I'mma start sending icing a stuff later
today I can't believe how fast the
provisional itself
Paso
get your Craig is it seemed please follow
this is setting up a senior first off yet
and slicing it to did it
Norm pass that okay package distribution
less than one package of pasta raise
I think it was misconstrued we did all this
wait what
we did all this going to need to do some
more condemned that's horrible code
we don't need any of that we don't need any
of that
we did that we did that mean that we can't
find
off and running synthesizer 6 year olds like
that really stood that did it did it did it
did it did it
as long as you can install Cinema
destruction pack murder he did this
do we actually need to do enable I don't
think we need to I think it does this by
default
wait what I seen it too is that not in there
oh well it's not there I ordered
PM install packages I feel instead of you
thanks already
I think it is I think it's there vagrants
SSH it is systems ETL
satisficing guy to well that's not good
and like I got installed
it looks like all the other stuff got
installed but it didn't get installed that's
what I'm going to
hey hi so so so yeah
and I singer
I mean why don't we do the import key first
I don't have to do
I see that I think we can do it in this
order
and then I don't I don't even think we need
I can put this all here
do it yourself screen
result Tim Oakes has a lot more
configurability I'm not a big fan of turning
I'm a big screen fan so at used to be pains
pains used to be a bit and they added that
right
in about that right that is paying support
to screen
haven't I mean me I was supposed to pay like
that that was not supporting screen for
years
but the number of
so this the status line down here is like a
marquee program that runs and it just loves
the content and puts it into their so again
I am a big advocate of not losing your
screen muscle memory because when you're on
a system that doesn't have tea mugs
obviously but and I've configure some of my
L key is control a default for two months
and I've changed all my other keys to match
screen and Mighty Max RC
self yep that's it says Valley question
though
like it without no screen exist they don't
even know it exists
came up this awesome thing I like Oh you
mean screen no around since the 70s
screen is almost as old as eunuchs it's one
of the oldest Utilities in the world it
would appreciate some mouse
well that seems to have work good let's do
vagrant
as soon as you get down there stereo system
c channel status I single to say it's on
it's just an active
all right so we need to enable it
and started
National trust's I wouldn't hear
yeah I would I would I would do this is not
original I got I got mine from somebody else
and it has all the exit be careful though
because I took over control see my control C
actually creates a new split pain because of
the streaming situation so you might not
wanted over take your country or your ears
you know you doing nothing I did though I
like it you can override it though that's
pretty damn cool and that was screened
since you unable when I really have about
this I can just keep adding this shit to my
script
and I don't have to you know it's going
around
bigger vision
damn it
that runs right
I see how this goes
sitting up check plug-ins yay
I think to do huh sacraments
bendy printed poses yeah that's who I tried
that yet this I think it doesn't have a good
talk with the Moe's
and I'm acting ignorant Yes actually vagrant
does use key move it uses live dirt
I'm in East Hartford for local Dev but it's
only if you have a cloud surprise surprise
to her phone doesn't work unless you have
the cloud
it's so I don't plan on using terraform
until I actually have a cloud to point it
locally which is trying to be proxmox of
openstack or something
but terraform I mean is he terraform is
because I'm sure you did tell me that many
people of something that I thought I would
try it and it did I did I actually got it to
work but it just it's just the whole point
of it is so that your end up learning
terraformed into deal with that I'm not
talking about a cloud cloud
and I'd like you to start what link did you
just share
going to break into structure I know it
which one you're talking about
I don't see a link you shared Ms Ms MS
Avicii I don't see one is a 8 minutes
are the doctor in pose yeah I tried that one
it doesn't work
I tried that one yeah I should have
mentioned that earlier that one doesn't work
I didn't work for me anyway I just ran it as
was and it didn't work
I didn't work yeah I tried it I tried that
like last week last week and like Wednesday
and a text because it didn't work I decided
I was going to try something else I think
that's the one is a chance I do to another
one it was the community's related
the second senior web server
it's not even as my beer different one
actually I probably driving
now in this case I I'm I'm fine with the
Baker and stuff I need to learn anyway
normally I would use a darker thing
but ya know I got here we're saying in fact
that many Cube plus that will probably give
me everything I need
Mini Cooper sat I'm actually almost positive
I haven't tried that image now I'm driving
looked at it
I tried one almost exactly like the same day
music was different
yeah I know that's why I'm saying that's why
the other day were okay the one that didn't
work now that I remember the one that didn't
work was the community's one I wonder when I
sing in kubernetes and
that's what didn't work
do to be fair okay I fully remember now to
be fair I did use that docker-compose and
then I tried to use composer the K to
convert it into coronavirus and running
kubernetes but I didn't run Standalone his
back then I was trying to I was trying to
get icing to work and get rid of these which
is stupid idea I think it is not meant
designed to work in kubernetes everybody
says don't do it there's a few people that
did get it to work and I still feel like
there's a there's a need for it but the
overwhelming consensus that I read was his
people think that I think I should be up and
stand alone and support outside of her brand
new so they can monitor communities it's
like the same reason your train your Dino
silver inside kubernetes even though you can
that's what failed that's why it failed so
so to be fair it's probably worth trying
that
as well and that that
not that without encapsulate the way all the
database it up and everything you know it's
part of me that wants to actually understand
I think I can maintain it because we do have
a nice thing as sincere as opposed to just
getting up and running and try to test the
rest API against it and I was doing
development against I think which is the
primary requirement here but that's kind of
secondary unspoken requirement to be able to
step in and support I seen that as well so I
think yeah I think I think that's totally
doable
yep I'm glad you reminded me of that
actually let me let me make sure to copy
link address I'm going to put the a little
note
am I read me about that
yeah game idea
I want that this
this is for how to install and configure
I sing a not just to get
it up so that you can test the rest API
for example
for such things not consider
you sing the docker compose
file in the related section
yep that's good to know though
how's it going malusis
here here I mean yeah my company most of the
time I don't know
I may have met my company may have met this
channel I made a minute and then in the
community
now that that's noted here so if you just
want to get it up and running go look at the
doctor and post well
I just put a warning to
how is weather warning when The Temptations
to get I sing out working in kubernetes
it's not supported and
has no precedent
I want to put that out there for people that
was a big rabbit hole
you can probably do it I just don't know
a Prometheus runs in the cloud Rider
Prometheus is designed to run in the cloud I
think I think we're going to see Prometheus
take over more and more because of that
but I don't know I don't know much about any
of them
all right so anything new look at my work
alright so we got icing it loaded
wow even has my history how is it keeping
track of my history
fuck a massive amount of the volume or
something
that's amazing that is something that
vagrant does that is not
it doesn't kept it kept my history it kept a
persistent history well it's a VM God damn
it it has a district I keep thinking of you
there's another reason
assistant I'm going to actually edit that
that then I was like
I was like wait myself still there cuz it's
not a femoral cuz it's a VM.
Oh yeah
vm's are persistent not ephemeral
myself after Sha
see him and wondering why my history and
everything was still there
then I remember
oh yeah Liam's are persistence
this is a reply the ephemeral
container mindset can creep up on you
with a surprise like this if you live in
kubernetes
container land all day
recipe for easy to humor I think that's
funny I think it's very damn funny
citizen reminder slices of his source is
difficult to choose so I wear a large
community
I go for free to find it because if it's
going to cause most people are we why do we
have that we have that as well we being the
place of work
but yeah
so
so that's a pie thing is up and it was Adam
before so that's good news
we're already up to the plugins
I mean yeah
what the fuck is the secret to does not know
how to check external services
do we do the one thing two
I guess so I'm slicing it too and we're just
going to take me to set up check plug-ins
without plugging since you didn't know how
to check provides an extensive property is
lichens are required to make the original
example configuration work on the box okie
dokie for your this for your for a
convenience package name from some of the
most popular operating systems
nagios plugins all oh my God
that looks pretty mono monolithic but
whatever we go
installation path UPL slides
action if everybody's going to wait as long
as their employees is to use or distribution
package manager I have no wish to make sure
your father just tell them to go look like
on Debian
and another thing to install OK Google
plug-ins all really that's it
well you know what I'm going to do you can
probably guess
all right and I guess plugins all
and then what all right running I sing it to
you let's go back
system D service already know that's working
we did that come and support Falls actions.
Restart that has enabled yet I know we use
that and
we use that and it's script
you just move a lot want you do not want you
seeing it was just a Sunday
SMS is meant for Access Control System along
such as a fine-grained from your system
is it going to provide its own as soon as
policy his passing has for Red Hat
Enterprise Linux 7 in derivatives
because runs on targeted runs a target of
policy which can finds I think it to
including an able to each other's and
running communes
I guess do I need it I wonder if we need it
I had a feeling we do because I think I
think Jesse Lennox comes on here but if all
right
does Cento us
this is a new thing I'm going to hit a lot
how's it going, sent to us come with
I thought he was saying the other day and I
think I remember hearing it come with
what is it called secret Lenox what is the
exact name
selinux yeah
it's a nice release officer since 2000
percent of 7
amazing concept security has Lennox as bad
as Castrol
isomers 50 to Summit retarded church or
greed
bring the commands as what user is a Lennox
I don't know if it's actually on here by
default this is the problem
I mean I guess it doesn't matter it doesn't
hurt to have it installed oh my gosh woohoo
that's a nice one.
That's funny cuz it is running in docker why
is it running darker though
oh it's running a doctor because vagrant is
docker
M uses a doctor process
that's why it is good to take care of all
the liver to Sakaya configuration problems
if you're having
Oriental Trading see if I can get at work or
I'll be right back
All rights back
you didn't knock out that's that's
interesting it wasn't doing that before they
change
another exit status
I think that's because I put Securus
security Lenox on it now I can't start
I think that's what's happening
a running slender Brothers
Ellipsis sized is that a word
still looks like a word a non-english
speaker put in which would not be the first
time
I feel like it was already there
I didn't see a sensationalist above
yeah I don't think I'm going to Sensations
is required
Christina I need it for vagrant right hey, I
don't need it I was just being honest the
station works
but it does make me wonder if it's even here
what is it
a 60 so there is an HD running
and I got I got got up from in a phone
so they apparently puts SSH on there by the
automatically did not know that is something
I learned today
I don't know if they'll steal anything is
required or not I feel like it's not
I don't know if I think the reason for the
failure is because it was already enabled
and I just did reload for vision
I mean I can do it and I can delete the
whole thing I think this because
one of the other steps does it how to start
a Singapore Service Unit not found
Chris has bigger and seems that this music
Medfield
I still says it's raining I understand
understand
I don't think we need to seal Onyx I don't
want to fucking say more
I don't fully understand what what failed
was everything is still running it's like
you know
I mean what actually did fail wonderful
reading without the provision
I think it might be re-running the provision
I see you in a single for that does not
exist
oh why is there a dish for on there anyway
that should have been icing it to the whole
time somehow I change that that was always
in there
that was always an error all right well that
explains a lot
I must have done something with me I wear I
like made it - 4 by putting the arrow keys
down at all I was on a number if you ever
done that so if he I buy the fault if you're
on a number and use a certain combination
it'll actually increase or decrease the
number I think that's what happened I think
that's what happened
that was it that was a stupid mistake but
it's fixed now
yeah let me know that's what I want and
that's what the problem is you control a
yeah hey guys this is exciting Reisinger
thinking provides configuration example
sentence as you let me know okie dokie
it sounds like a damn sure add-ons not
interested
hello there my singing audition vs. package
manager
then add on manager I didn't know that was a
thing I got a nice here today and I don't
I've never used that ever I honestly did not
know that was a thing
yum install in my sing I am okay with that
was try that
it's actually working vagrant
I mean this is kind of fun because it's
going to have like everything
I think him a little longer than I wanted I
got till 12 to do this
and then we're going to move on to testing
it by sending message to it
him am I single
sister shaking is on tested amazon.com
I mean
Joe is like a a non plug-in that doesn't get
home like a feminine install
that's stupid answersa stupid answer to
Justin Bieber
I'm going to edit a s
nothing is there oh
it look like it's doing it
I mean I did it was worth it though so
whatever I'm not going to do that anyway I
would rather not do that
I sense if I can work I don't care
say yes yes
hey it worked yeah I just need to log into
shell
that looks happy
I don't know if I'm ready to mail thing but
I'll see to all right
and I didn't miss a single dad of a future
with you takes care of exporting
I figured you be ideal and it might as well
as long as you all
we need to do it I don't think we all think
our databases actually need one right now it
where do it though stress
statues
asphyx is on there not postgres who is
spelled it right
that would make me think it's not a song
guess where we saw it though
Oscar Cisco
all right arrested
SQL he asked if I was there
Trevor Wallace
I think it's probably a stand-alone thing
Grandpa postgres no it's not there
installing postgres on Centos 7
documents my address
let's just work single Siri PS4 Smith in a
sorcerer or a motherfuking using putty
I am a Starbucks Reserve Bar Express can't
read
twitch which is better for the kind of
screaming I do
I invented the Tipsy to build a community
better and it makes you make more money on
Twitch
YouTube is for videos of sniper streaming
this article that stream and do very well
stream and do very well on YouTube but it's
if they have communities already here trying
to build a community you can't or won't
because he can't find you
that's if you can read it all about that all
over if you do a search that's what
everything pretty much says
Henry version this
what the hell
a Grinch rinone provision
and I think it's just a client to I am going
to need the gland to though
yeah I didn't like any of that that was
still kind of should look that up
yeah I swear I saw the maintained postgres
for two years and I'll be home in 20
2006 first came out it was just bad only
been released for like 2 or 3 years
and now I my skills honored I print out all
the poster stocks and really I really love
both of us really knew
yay inactive so
I mean this is his good, I like all the
steps in one place
i k and Randy be
song EIEIO modules I'm going to bet you
there isn't a single idea postgres
hey there hiya
I'm still acting everything
well what do you know there is nothing to do
and that is me guessing
nothing at all damn it well we got to do
some research Sun
I sing a nice Minnesota icing idea packages
here
I single audios for postgres
so we can find singer reporting
installation
postgres
oh boy
am I just shipped to David smokes for
calculating the host and service available
today as far as that you are singing it is
interesting
is that the various just dropped this module
isolation just dropped this module to an
ideal report some folder in your single web
path
that doesn't look right I know reports
I saw the idea model for my child
I doesn't look as supported
I wish it were at the credit database my
Singa
yeah I guess we're just going to shell
script and I have to put it in at the mall
or something
I don't want to do this but I guess we have
to do this is probably all configured
automatically but I kind of want to get into
the assignment
I was just very smart calculator how to
spell stress
are you
I sing a
if you have to run a thing to do it yeah you
can just do the module
after the nice lights are too big
if you can't do it from there's no module to
install nope
no module
all right so we're going to have to replace
those steps
with this and which ones are going to have
to send a base up first and then doing
pricing to Route I did was I single
I never have to do that I slept her is going
to slack a percent
Davis Wells sitting
I single with less grass
the most recent singer finish the tree.
I think I did okay ask you do
no such file
b p g s u l a h r o w how is it going
did you ask you come on baby
that's what we wanted to see all right exit
you go here
and are nice
seems like a nice day it's a beautiful day
in the neighborhood
and the union representing and then wait we
do have Project Playlist rap
Dash Dash provision
my fan is on
my fan is on god dammit that means my
computer is working too hard
I was dming all this VM up and Downing
goddamnit
Chris and Link from Little River
the Control process are you the codes for
SimCity Phil says postal service for Journal
perseverance I don't understand
your onlyfans no I'm not
I how are you Daniel
yay
oh you get my fan I just I just got it 20
points for the horrible joke
why is it not working when do it again
obviously if I try it again it'll work this
time
I just keep trying until it works
already wait already installed already
installed already installed
I understand I don't feel like
officiated already installed how many Aria
salt why am I getting all these are
installed
job for your service failed because the
first contact with a terror I don't
understand
journalctl that shake see postgres I guess
because it was already there
I'm fine bulshit
what the hell those are postgres database
how the Starbucks Trenta base enter why
didn't run
systemctl status statues
I switch from Regular Show Santos stream I'm
going to be doing sentence a lot yeah for
sure
because it's Enterprise I have been doing a
lot of Enterprise Community stuff I run pop
OS so or dead man so you know
both of us. Do do do do
active failed
starts tell because Control process exited
with error
surface Chris
Summersville why though
customer service failed I'll just started
failed to start it
why did Fela start 4 cm is it from here to
look at the database logs
it was working before so
I think I just did that today.
I can turn off yeah that's what I just did
but doesn't say why
did you like CS Pedialyte
we're going to need to do
can I spend a long time it's been so long
I am so stuff I need to work with them I
think I think
I think it's snowing the malls are broken
I know I like this method though because
this tells me exactly what architecture
broke it you know
and infostride a directory so is it okay
watch this if I provision is
it was I bet you it'll work there's
something in the module that idea module
that breaks it
and caused a postcard from not being able to
run
that's my theory I really like this
incremental provisioning approach to vagrant
because it's like the incremental you know
debugging of a shell script except for at a
macro level
did you do something yeah I remember where
it is either
and creates a halt
that's actually just read yes
fragrance
I mean I guess it was in the package it was
something else I want to see asking Lennox
package that was doing it
purveyor the port was already taken in and
tried to open up again or something
and something to do I have I've been feeling
had something to do with the provisioning
not resetting everything
but I don't know hey how's it going and it
gets
download packages
is it getting all the new stuff is an
absolute fresh GM install so nope same
problem
cleaning machine folder
where is a port forward fail
you did not found
2022 if you're being forced to learn it yes
I wouldn't learn it by choice unless you're
going to do mobile development
who makes me wonder I wonder if it has to be
in order
Miss was the clients that shouldn't make any
difference
something has stopped working we need to go
back and slowly and figure out what it is to
stop working cuz it was working before I
thank you
unless you have Resources phone number and
it's not just that it's I mean we will but
it's not just that his other stuff
so yeah
I don't even think I made it yeah a trigger
of won't work until that's gone
which makes me wonder hey Hector I don't
know how it even was able to do it tell you
the truth
I don't something changed
so when I turn those two off and see what we
can start it on our own
vagrant up
when you get back up and then we'll go check
the first logs and start it individually
it was working though
this is the job this is the operation Shadow
fortunately this is like the sis off job do
you have to be able to install the shed and
get it configured and also stripped it and
coat it and stuff
this is operations
staring at screens scrolling past
I know there's no gas Wiggins that's weird
what part of the script that I break I broke
something in here and I do not know what it
is
I think it
it's funny because it was before and I just
read provisioning
it wasn't as broken or some reason
I'm still blaming I'm going to blame those
those icing ideas for UPS
I think that they fuck with supposed to go
somehow
because we had I think it was coming up
before it was due it was fine it didn't
happen until we did the idea who posed for
Stuff
in fact I wonder if it has to have a
configure database before we install it
Nadia stuff I mean it does because I've been
at tries to talk to post for us in the
configure stuff even though the step says
that comes after
if
or at least have something to connect you
now
so now what
I mean seashell
inactive systemctl enable
Edwards I unfreeze be a delay and we might
have to put it away there
I meant I bet you either that or I can't
return it like I 14 something for some
reason
enable now why I never done that
I wonder is that can afford to be
asynchronous
oh and Abel starts at so she can buy and did
not know that that's super cool
loaded there we go
Health Star Plus dress
process starts his first check debeader PG
data code Exodus acidifier
of a dress
barlog nothing here
it has to be the only thing that changed was
that module that was the only thing that
changed
is in Berlin
pgs Grill
what is versing France versus to new could
be then I don't see anything here this is
srpg astronomist nope
PG current load file
therapist vs. Fiora with locks
Sherlock destination can't do it it's there
snow postgres running
and we must be missing something
astride address for this
I said they're doing there
did you ask you out hey.
Stars
I mean kind of found them roots
it's the right any logs though no
well
I'm going to transmit this is why we use
vagrant I just want everybody who's
questioning why am I using vagrant this is
exactly why do you imagine having to throw
away a system and restart it after ripping
out of thing every time
can you imagine it can you imagine the
work-related for that it would be insane
yeah where to do one piece at a time
something has changed and so this is how we
actually what has changed so
intercept is already on there that's why I
have to do for reprovision
I don't think it's going to do it because
the other stuff is already installed
so destroyed
destroy
I just I just have to say how grateful I am
to be able to script this if you if she
couldn't script this oh my God
it would be a disaster mention having to
like reinstall maschine a fresh install
every time I was doing this it would take me
a week
because I have to take it down and have to
reinstall with the right stuff in it from
scratch on Hardware it's insane how fast
everything is gotten because of
virtualization
I mean I can actually isolate the bad line
as soon as I say infrastructure as code I'm
literally managing infrastructure as code by
iterating immiserating over the different
solutions
we don't need a new TV oh and did you be
certain the enabled postgres system b a
start
no I'll be really bad I would be really
surprised if that's true
it was actually starting before that's why
I'm confused
I mean it was starting
yeah I have that one I was looking at that
one but we'll go look at it again that one
is the one that has the unit stuff in it but
I don't think I think that extra in this
stuff is only if you need it I can be wrong
now
so
systemctl that might describe something else
so I might go check your system C2
enable that's that's no
no it's still not working I don't know
I swear to God it was working I swear to God
we had it working
I don't know if you know if we need
phosphorus contribute to this says okay we
are missing one thing we're missing
set up an IP TV
I don't know why we needed it to be I but
I'm going to do it that's what they said to
do
it doesn't make sense of it or need it
are they want you to run that can I see I
see
they want us to run that yeah yeah yeah okay
that's what you're saying I'm sorry
that's very odd
initializing database
so they actually wanted you to have a
database you shouldn't have to do that
no I do not think that is required
yeah but if you know maybe maybe they're
module but again I didn't load their module
I got rid of it right so
hey Mom puss Chris I mean why would you have
to build a database before your navel here
but it works
I stay up with you anymore that's just now
watch it work only shit
it works so I don't question I just do what
works
well we got the bottom of that one that's
good I learn a lot
provision I turn this to fall back on
and Studio
yeah I don't know that's weird it works
don't question it it's like
bring it I'll see if this is enough
not to destroy it all again it should be
I supposed to be the reprovision but we'll
see
hey Claus
sort of Happy it's sort of Happy
cross your fingers 00
my fans coming on my only fan
it's so interesting what vagrant burning
stuff with vigor
damn it now I sing is mad
all right but but I haven't
plus dresses up worried about me SSH no a
word that it's worth
it's working
sorry if that's too bad I couldn't resist
it did mostly work it most of her cuz I
give me the status statues systemctl status
first currency post grass SQ it's activate
running yay
I think it is that's very possible
it is very very possible actually we can
check that
yes we have ways of checking so we can check
I sing a song to
which is active so
I mean it's up why was it unhappy ask me
that again
I don't even remember
I have your back it up till like 5
show up no that's too easy I just way too
easy Catherine Jose again
hey there we go at work see
see all right
hurry someone save it while it's all working
it's all the modules okay we did that we did
that
I know it wasn't for scratchy right but it
still works
CV resume look look
our script continues to grow
all right still seems to have worked
next one create that single database oh I
know it totally is
yep absolutely is and I single an ansible
think so after this after the script gets
done then I'll put in an ansible and then
I'll tie vagrant to dance ansible which
what should my child be to dependencies but
whatever
phone cannot change direction to Home
vagrant
okay I don't care their work
this is a nice going we're going to go back
we have like 2 tutorials going on now save
us or save us
I don't think I need this one I think he's
having either there
locate your pghboe in a configuration file
and additional user with md5 as of indicated
I said some pretty hairy insulation steps
play singer
tattoo the good thing I know VI right God
what if I only knew Emax right now
My Life Would Suck permission denied.
Bite me pseudo call Cece
oh did you see the kill I actually want a
video about how to activate them yeah we
took me awhile but
is install instructions of Soul 1990s
imagine just knowing that hoe I know
I didn't they did they being my workplace
and so now I'm forced to talk to it even
though I don't not sure I would do for me to
screw phone at today
as my main thing if I had to pick but but
they have I single leftover and it's a core
thing until after they're not talking to it
and understand it it's I think it's out
there are a lot of single in audiosurf out
there
so so what do we put in here
I'll go see you soon so I can system she's
out restart postgres now in front of these
lines in there
yeah alright what if we just counted them
onto the end of it I think that's what we
can do
going to have to use my cutting his buffer
huzzah huzzah huzzah restart
Sirius system this is like this is the job
people
walking around with stuff like this
that seems to have worked I think that's the
Kennedy for provision change
pseudo I can't
no I go
Echo to the eom all of this shit
nope 2
that
I can be sure what's a latest version
cuz it's running on the system
eventually need to go in and icing a thing I
am
this is actually running on the machine so
it gets it gets copied over apparently
it's my first time using a single yep I'm
just saw him for the first time getting used
to it I have to write some monitoring
software that works with it at work so I
need to learn it real quick really quickly
just in time learning people
just-in-time learning if learn something
like everyday in like an hour or two if you
can't you just job is not for you
if you don't want to do that if you're
unwilling to do that
you like it we probably could have written
this are I just realized
I just realized we can probably do the
restart after this
I don't care
I need to write
an application that calls a rest API to send
a check to it if you have any information
about that I would appreciate it
I'm from Cooper Nettie's I need to check on
a filled storage class that's backing PBC
specifically for Domino and then tell I sing
about it so we can notify us
because you don't have me this everything
else doing it I mean we could do it for me
this but
back 3 yd
about an hour I'm exaggerating it took me a
while I've been working on this since 9 my
you know
you going to be able to learn pretty complex
talking about a day and you have to
constantly be learning new things and I'm
learning that I've fallen behind on a bunch
of stuff already
so that's kind of the it's kind of the thing
I know I mean the specifics aside the job is
constantly refreshing your knowledge of
whatever is immediately necessary I
installed and deployed postgres at 8 p.m. to
handle the data store with terabytes of
information for 52,000 machines for out of
compliance and I have no fucking idea how to
do Post rest today I did that in 2006 so the
point is you're constantly cycling your
knowledge you're always cycling your
knowledge and you know I did not get us a
long time ago I mean there's always
something is coming to the Forefront that
you have to relearn a remember and so having
I like a really amazing no taking strategy
and and being you want me to sing with
hacking right in being able to to learn
quickly and to refresh your brain cuz your
memory is not going to be able to remember
everything like me
the concept stay the same there'splay the
saying there's monitoring there's databases
that kind of thing I just got comfortable
yeah
yeah and I I hate losing this time but but
it's a part of the job I mean you can't you
can't work with technology until you
understand it and if you try you're going to
end up being in more trouble and I probably
spent too much time researching Tech but I
have to because I don't feel comfortable in
a breaking a thing nothing to you need to be
able to run your own lab and this is my
opinion there's a lot of people who do not
agree with me that tennis us agree with me
and I are just wrong and respect him as it
energy or he's one of our streamers over
here had underscore tennis and to do the
minimum and not do any of this and that's
fine too I know I'm not that person vasotec
is basically service waiting for external
input while not excluding active check
possibility yeah
that's the thing I was afraid of because I I
mean if it says anything like doggy to see
if they can write a monitor for it right
well what is it that's that's kind of pull
Monitor and
I'm going to have to write a check that I
can talk to I'm going to push the
notification
and I don't I don't remember Nadia's having
push methodology
it was more about you write a check and then
it would go out and do the thing is that
more of a pole do with the Demi check yeah
that's what I was afraid of because it is
more of a whole system in a push right about
that and basically saying do the minimum and
it shows and I will give you the fun stuff
basically you with the extra mile you could
do the fun stuff and sulli
yeah
and that's that's what I get for a
contractor you don't get to do the fun stuff
anyway because the full-time people get all
the fun stuff
so you better make sure that you have
another source of fun in your life like
livestream because they're not going to give
you the fun stuff you're just a lowly
contractor doesn't matter at this is
something I learned in my I'm totally okay
with it so anyway
have a great day miss versus you to import
the audio database schema to find command
yeah it's always a price to be a contractor
there's there's supposed to take us to being
a contractor right
and there's lots and lots of benefits to it
it has given take it's like should you be a
contractor or not there's a whole
conversation that we should probably do a a
Sunday call-in talk day on that just thought
it should be a contractor or not what the
contractor life vs. Contractor life they're
very different jobs
yeah so
you're thinking about it as being a
contractor I've noticed is that even if my
immediate so there's a kind of their kind of
the Dilemma
as a contractor they deliberately are not
going to give you the stuff that will avenge
your career and be fun to do
it doesn't mean they're being mean they just
like to keep that work for their full-time
staff and that's totally understandable I
would do the same thing
but that means that if you want to stay
current and the ironic thing is to sit as a
contractor the reason you're a contractor is
because you can pop around in your being
expected to know the latest and greatest
thing so you can work on any engagement
anytime so teksystems can place me with
another company and it's up to you to keep
up-to-date even if the Contracting the
company that account for what you're working
doesn't give a shit about you and they maybe
there's some I remember having some
contractors when I was a Nike that they sat
in my cubicle a program that just sucked all
my data out of me they had no idea how to do
shit it couldn't do anything and I resent it
actually talked to my manager I said this
contractor is actually costing us money
because I'm spending all my time training
them they're pretty much an intern I said I
don't know how much money you're paying this
person but you need to stop and so
as a contractor it's your job to not get in
the way first of all and that means a lot of
times during your ass to do or suggesting
proposing things in and having them okay if
for you because you need to be different I
I've learned this the hard way you need to
be different to the people that are
employing you at the account they are the
bosses they're the ones and you don't resent
them for doing the fun stuff that's their
job you were there to help them that is your
job
that is your job and if they don't give you
the fun stuff you still have to learn the
fun stuff you have to learn it somehow and
guess what the reason that that is the stuff
that you have to do you somehow on your own
time or you have to be able to rationalize a
certain amount of time doing that on the
clock because you can't be a decent contract
with that doing it if you spend all of your
time on the clock charging the customer for
learning is something that you should
already know or something that might be
crossing over like this contractor that talk
to me it's one thing to spend a lot of time
learning on your own and then getting up to
speed so you can help the company in the
contract that's one thing it's another thing
to sap the time of the people for whom
you're trying to help that's not okay it's
never okay and you keep doing that you get
fired
I know because we had a contractor fired for
that very reason they have no business being
there probably getting double we are
probably paying him double or triple my
salary
hi I know this is my first time
is my first time a first-year being a
contractor or coming up on I'm coming up on
a Fleer I really like it but I just trying
to tell you don't feel guilty spending time
keeping up to date on things because your
contracting company that hires that are
Contracting firm doesn't care about you as a
company they don't care about you and their
people are going to put their full-time
people above you which means you've got to
enter if you work for a Nexus to do
something like that they have a meeting
every week and they provide tons of
resources and training and stuff like that
so you can keep up-to-date
the nearest ramen ya yeah yeah
I know right I don't want to give you the
fun projects that will get you a job next or
leave they because they give those to their
full-time people so I'm just telling the new
Dynamic of Contracting and you I love you
too since you can give $0.25 if you want
is this yeah he was having freedom
oh God yeah as much anyway they do have some
but not as much as my wife's a genius
she is have I tried startups yeah I run to
start straight years
the person you're a business person or you
have a partner as a business person
yeah don't do it I don't do a startup
not by yourself anyway I did was a bad idea
I loved it is one of my greatest
accomplishments the greatest times but I
would never recommend etemad again
especially in America where you have no
safety net for 8 years I had no insurance
contractors are not paid more no God no
contractors the company that contracting
company is paid more
the number I read over and over again is 60%
if you take what you make as a contractor
and you add on 60% that's the money that
you're making out there in industry
cuz like if you were going to be hired full
time if you want to accept a full-time
position
that's how much overhead they have to pay to
have you be there I believe that and most
companies don't give a shit most most big
companies the money issue is not an issue
until it becomes an issue and then they
start chopping people high
I yes okay let's go for a walk
I'm going for a walk I'll be back I don't
know when though
I'll see you in a bit
haven't going to stop the stream I'm sorry
having some lunch I'll be right back as soon
as I should have killed it when I went out
for a walk
I know I'm here but I think I'm going to go
ahead and take a break and restart the
stream to that